H
777 I didn't smoke so much crack um I
was born in 77 so makes me like 46
right
damn when did you start smoking crack
when I was
15 who who introduced you to crack
cocaine a man for um extracurricular
activities so maybe this a party on it
get
high have
sex
party move around it was a little bit
different back then it was real cocaine
was it better man you we used to smoke
out a gerber jar with a matches you used
to take all the matches off the book and
You' set them up two by two by two
Gerber jar with a little
straw and um man this get so [__]
like High high so high that um I think I
stayed in a room for like two days
tweaking this this cocaine we got now is
kind of like a tweak drug get up and
move around tweak Pop Lock And [__]
around and but yeah back then it was
U it was mindblowing I got stuck have
you been using ever since then yes wow
um I've been in prison behind crack I
didn't raise my kids behind
crack
um like crack has been my life my
parents have always understood
but like I often ask myself like why I
put crack before everything like it's I
wake up with my pipe in my hand my
lighter like I fall out like this and
soon as I open my eyes oh my god do I
have to do I have a pipe do I and I sit
up and I take a hit start the monster
all back over again and pardon me I
don't want to quit I'm old now my kids
are raised they're grown who ra your
kids my mom your mom my dad if they
hadn't raise them I don't know where
they would
be you know I what's the most
humiliating thing you've done to get
your get your
crack help somebody for
ransom
um oh man for $100,000 that I never
thought I would ever do like I was so
crack oh man I look like a
wolf did you get the
money yes and no we got the money but we
got I got a prison sentence the DEA took
me down like I'll never forget that it
was all over the news and
um I was just feing like that's not in
your natural personality no to do that
kind of stuff no the drugs are would
drive it man my my addiction is a beast
like you know somebody can smoke a 20 or
40 a day smoke 700 800 ,000 a day like I
have to take a hit like every 10 minutes
and you smoke too much of course I put
tens and 20s on the
pipe um it's not about common sense is
it no it's not about like oh this is bad
for me I should stop it's listen it is
it is but my logic tells me like this is
fun this is it and you're going to do
whatever it takes to get more yes
whatever it takes whatever whatever I've
died off of fit and all I wanted some
crack that day so bad I begged this boy
for some crack and for some reason I
never pray over my drugs but I prayed
over that crack rock I said Lord you
know please you know make sure there's
no F Hall and as soon as I hit it I told
him call 911 that's fit and all that's
all I
remember fractured how many times have
you OD like that just once at the police
station with a handful of crack rocks
and they even packed my bong in my bra
when I got to the hospital the doctor
was like what is this I was like oh let
me have that I left the hospital and I
didn't even go home I came right back
downtown looking for some more
crack it was um I I guess I was passed
out for 12 minutes they said they
fractured my sternum trying to revive me
um and I was out here bent over I
couldn't even
walk still hustling to get crack more
crack I'd be crying for crack it's
sad but listen it becomes your top
priority right it is my top priority
it's at the top of my list every day
more than your kids more than
your I haven't talked to my daughter in
years my son um my none of my kids do
drugs and they know about my addiction
my son tries to talk to me you know tell
me you know Mom if you die out here
nobody cares but me you know you got to
get clean if you want to be around your
grandkids you think I went to a program
or I've stopped no still pulling like a
locomotive I love I love that feeling of
getting high I love that numbness and it
still it still goes on after all these
years oh yes I make sure I smoke out of
bong I make big old I'm not even a
crackhead I'm a free baser like I really
get high up for
weeks you don't you don't sleep right
uhuh smoking how how many days do you go
without
sleep maybe 10 10 days with no sleep
delusional my feet reflect how much like
I really tell me about cavy feet
man I don't know cuz I can't feel him I
smoke too much crack but if you look
cavy feet is when you've been up for
days yes but if you look at them they
look like they hurt
big old rips in them look like I've been
on the see people tiptoeing around skid
Ro that's that's why I got these Wiis on
right now because my feet hurt my feet
hurt so bad they won't even fit in the
shoe but that's all right I'm still G to
move around my feet look like I've been
on the freeway with um Fred and Barney
you know how they use their feet for
braks and it doesn't matter they'll be
hurting and I'll still find a way catch
a bus jump on a scooter get in a wagon
somebody pull me get in a shopping C
where do you stay are you in a tent no
uh I stay in Lynwood but listen I don't
want to be there I've been in this house
for three years but they always ask me
why you don't want to be at home because
there's no [__] crack there you'd
rather be here yep L I said I have a
house very nice house you'd be happy I'm
happy here staying right here in a tent
or whatever not even a tent I just sit
on the curb and smoke watch the police
go by smoke at the police station what
are you doing nothing nothing if you get
out my way I'm about to get high yep I
sit right at the police station right
there on that wall safest place to get
high safest place skid Rose in addicts
Paradise man the cops won't even bother
you listen they they let you get high
they don't care about no [__]
pipes the fetty heads they would need
they would need 20 not 20 they need 200
school buses full of no you need you
need about 500 school buses
people some people don't even want to
move out of downtown the drugs are
accessible you could you don't have to
buy food um they're going to feed you
every day you can go to the missions you
get free
clothes um the people come down and feed
give you money tell you believe in Jesus
might be a $10 bill in there man passes
out Bibles there $50 $100 bills do you
think that I'm going to take that $50 or
that $100 bill home no straight to the
crack man I was just telling him he was
like what are you going to do with your
money I was like I'm going to go buy a
and smoke to Oblivion all day today and
there's there's all kinds of programs
here for people to get clean but nobody
seems to be going for it there's
programs to get clean down here yeah
where at the
missions
oh you know let me tell you I didn't
know that I thought those were just for
the homeless
people we all know that those places are
not for nobody to get clean how are you
going to put a drug addict in a high
drug area where drugs are so accessible
they let you smoke them all day long and
you're going to get clean right here you
can get on the other side of that wall
you can get what you
want not even other side of wall you can
send somebody out to go get it simple
simple this is not the place to get
clean you're going to relapse that's why
half these people are on the streets
they came down here with good
jobs even work for um skid Road housing
and Trust Housing Authority they're down
there pushing pipes now I matter of fact
I was just smoking with a case manager
from the wiu I say you're a case manager
just by being down here you'd becomeing
ad it's in the air there's so much drugs
in the air it it just
lingers everywhere you go you can't help
see somebody with a needle in their arm
a pipe in their mouth Pusher don't thing
you hear do you got a hit do you got a
pusher you got some crack can I get a 50
you got some Crystal you got a Pookie
pipe matter of fact they give out um
free pipes now with Brillo p pipes the
whole kit to use use if you use needles
they give you
everything you don't have to pay for it
no more you think you'll be down here
the rest of your
life literally I'm trying to smoke into
oblivian literally I love that feeling
and like I said my kids are grown I
should be able to do what the [__] I
want I want to stay high for the rest of
my life to the next lifetime what's your
biggest
regret not raising my
kids don't know them and because I've
been smoking drugs so long I've been
numb to
the numb to the feeling of being a mom
yeah and the shame makes you want to
just smoke the guilt
yeah I want
to but I don't want to face everything
that comes with it that's right
what do you think people that don't do
drugs don't understand about a drug like
craco everybody's addiction is
different mind's not an addiction mind
is a
disease if you don't smoke
dope you can't place your feet in my
shoes not every day do I want to get up
and put a pipe in my
mouth
some days I do want to be
clean just for that
minute till reality KES back
in and I have to get
high to deal with all the [__] that I've
been
through the men touching me being
raped it doesn't just you don't wake up
one day and say you want to be a drug
addict for reaction is a
reaction it's the only way I can numb
the
pain
sadly if you've never done drugs
don't judge a drug ad you don't know
what they've been
through I
hurt
deeply but cocaine covers over all
that oh that I get happy when I think
about
it what's your biggest what's your
biggest fear
now I'mma die with a crack pipe in my
mouth when I overdosed I overdosed
um the day before Father's Day I would
have been devastating to my
son you know my mom just passed my
spouse
passed and
um he said you know Mom you're going to
die with crack pipe in your mouth and he
said I'm going to be the only one to go
to the morg to identify you cuz I'm the
only one who
cares and every day I tell myself I
don't want to die with this in my mouth
but I also don't want to put it
down I know what it takes to go get
clean sober it's not what I want to
do not right
now I'm not hurting
nobody I'm getting high and what's the
difference in me getting high and the
rich people getting high they just have
more money and we don't see their
actions I'm just out street for everyone
to
see but I don't want to die with a crack
pipe him in my
mouth if you had your life to live all
over again what would you have done
differently
i' have been a mother I raised my
children not messed around with that guy
when you were
nope I would have put my kids
first but drugs had already consumed
me so I was already
lost my mom was a a drug addict my mom
smoked
cocaine I remember I was like seven or
eight years old a dope man threw a lit
match in my hair and he burned hurt me
my mom didn't even
care her husband molested me she didn't
care my mom got clean us over
though she alwaysed to tell me don't try
to swim in the ocean you'll drown but if
you just tread water she said you'll
make
it so I'm just treading
water just
treading hopefully I make
it
hopefully Z what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
life that being a drug addict though we
think that we're not hurting anybody
else and we're only hurting
ourselves we're hurting the ones that
love us the most worse the cause and the
effect you know I my boy is like 27
years
old
and he'll break down into
tears tell me mom I need you I need you
to be clean and
sober but it doesn't bother me it hurts
me but it doesn't bother
me cuz I've been doing it all his life
so he's used to it he
understands he does but he doesn't he he
does because I'm his mom but he doesn't
understand why I keep putting that
first and not a relationship with
him I want to I wish God you would just
one day just zap me and you're a
mom but it's not the reality so until
then I'll just keep hitting my pipe
hoping that it takes the pain
away
hoping that it covers over all the ill
feelings that I have the shame and the
guilt you know my mom passed and I smoke
so much dope she begged me to come see
her before she died I couldn't put my
crack pipe
down that the day I finally put it down
to get some
sleep she
passed you know when I got to her
mailbox check the mail she had ordered
my birth certificate two weeks prior cuz
she knew she was going to
die and the lady was so loving during my
whole addiction with cancer and
chemotherapy and radiation she used to
drive to Skid
R just to see me sick and
all and I remember her telling me you
know know I'm going to check out the
hospital
tonight I just want to go home and she
said I'm doing really good I want you to
come see
me she already knew she was
dying but all I wanted I didn't have
enough crack to go I I didn't I need to
make some more money
and the guilt and the shame just eats me
alive
eats me
alive and hopefully she'll forgive me
one
day hopefully I'll forgive
myself all right Zenovia thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
wish you all the luck in the world thank
you